14h30 une grande partie du personnel a
convergé vers la cafétéria de
l'établissement dans la salle au moins
400 personnes parmi le personnel médical
et non médical
venu rencontrer le directeur de la rs
dont la venue était souhaitée depuis
plus de 6 mois vous avez subitement sert
marché ce gps de votre voiture
depuis des mois et des mois était en
panne le maire de chalon qui est aussi
président du conseil de surveillance de
l'hôpital affirme que le personnel ait
accord pour un plan d'économies mais pas
à n'importe quelle condition
la limite à ne pas dépasser elle est la
limite à ne pas dépasser
c'est que on ne dégrade pas ni le
service public rendu aux patients ni les
conditions de travail et donc la vie des
agents du service pendant deux heures
ils sont plusieurs dizaines à prendre la
parole pour exprimer leur colère face à
un plan d'économies qui l'ont rejetée en
avril dernier pour la première fois de
la vie de l'hôpital
il doit pourtant être appliquée dès
lundi 17 janvier au désarroi du
personnel nous a donné nouveaux horaires
pour lundi or je pensais que ça se
décide aujourd'hui à priori déjà tout et
fait donc un film qui peut étonner on
nous a déjà dit que c'était 15 rtt et
les nouveaux horaires sont faits les
infirmiers anesthésistes dont le bloc
opératoire est en grève illimitée depuis
plusieurs jours annonce alors vouloir
durcir le mouvement
avant de quitter la salle une colère
froide vient ensuite d'arnaud des linges
et ancien président du comité médical
d'établissement
interpellé par le directeur de la rs
j'appelle au contraire à une prophétie
de bonheur je souhaite que cette
opération aboutisse et pour un outil
elle doit que sortir de l'hypocrisie
devenue sans solution le directeur de la
rs et parfois huées par le personnel qui
appellent même à la démission de la
directrice
la rs campell sur ses positions l'idée
n'est certainement pas de sortir le
rabot pour raboter jusqu'à éliminer ce
déficit qui certes est une menace pour
cet établissement
l'idée c'est vraiment de trouver des
réponses structurelles au coeur de
l'organisation de l'établissement et ça
eh ben ça ne se fait pas en 24 heures ça
ne descend pas libérés
ça se prouve ce sont des clés qui se
trouve au sein de l'hôpital au sein des
communautés hospitalières
au sein de chaque service finalement
cette assemblée générale tant attendu
aura accouché d'une souris
aucune solution concrète n'a été
proposée par la rs1 personnel de
l'hôpital en souffrance et qui promet
déjà de nouvelles actions dans les
prochains jours